all right welcome everybody
i understand there was some snackage
going on so i won't be surprised if we
have a few more people wander in
and hello everybody out there in the
virtual space
this says we're talking about accessible
experiences
but we're really going to talk about
equitability
and making your best
content
my goals for this session are to offer
some grounding concepts for equitable
content creation and access
introduce visual description and expose
some of the complexities inherent in
aesthetically equitable multiplex
experience
and hopefully successfully demo a fun
little implementation that's designed to
make these principles actionable for
almost any kind of content
this session is applicable to you if you
are a developer a designer a manager a
content creator or a human who likes art
or any number of those things
i'm a product architect and ct of a
boutique consultancy that specializes in
multi-domain systems architecture r d
and novel problems my personal specialty
is high reliability ui and there could
be a couple digressions about design
philosophy
if we head that way
i am also a professional dancer and
choreographer
it's not often that i come to tech
conferences wearing all of these hats
but this is a lot of what i've been
working on for the last five years in
all my fields this research and
development largely happened in
collaboration between my consultancy and
kinetic light which is a collective of
disabled artists working at the
intersections of disability access race
gender dance and tech
if questions come to you please raise
your hand someone else's hand the
nearest furniture and i'll try to take
them in line
and if possible i'll try to leave a few
minutes at the end you can also
drop it in the slight channel of course
and i'll try to check in there later in
the conference
tweet at me and if you want to get in
deeper or play with the demo i will be
professionally available for the rest of
the conference
let's do a lightning round of the
fundamentals
accessibility
is not compliance
is not a checklist
is not after the fact
accessibility is culture
is conversation
is capacity that exists within all of us
access is a way of expressing the
factual reality of community and of
interdependence
sometimes people resist providing access
because they don't want to acknowledge
the ways in which access has been
provided to them
the
toxic and
really kind of hilariously laughable
idea that receiving help is somehow
shameful
yo
i'm pretty sure everyone here
came through infancy i don't think any
of us emerged full grown from a vat
if you did please let me know i would
love to hear about it
so at some point in your life you have
needed deserved and hopefully gotten
help
access is not one size fits all
content which is created
to provide accessibility
should be given the same care
as your initial medium
equitable
this is often a hard one
[Music]
if you were going to have a dinner party
would you invite people into your home
and give one person a beautiful plated
multi-course dinner and offer somebody
else a sandwich
and then expect them to sit down
uh together and not have feelings about
that
notice that i'm not using the words
inclusion
or universal in reference to this work
those concepts are
directly harmful
to real equity universal design is
actually a great way to avoid centering
the users you ought to be focusing on
and that my friends is a whole other
talk
so i won't go any further with that just
now
aesthetics
a set of principles
usually relating to
understanding art
in this case
accessibility as a way of understanding
the work that you're making
and
your ability expanding your ability to
communicate it and for other people to
experience it
of course these principles can be
applied to basically anything
it really doesn't matter
they work pretty well across the board
but today i'm using the experience of
art
let me actually go
back here
multiplex experience
the equal validity of experiencing the
world in different ways
if i see something but i don't hear it
and you hear it but don't see it we are
not having an equivalent
experience
but it's possible that we're having an
equitable
experience
this is something
that we as content creators
as people who create platforms for the
consumption
and distribution content that we as
artists
i think should be striving for
this is something that
disabled people understand in community
that there are many ways of interfacing
understanding
sensing
interacting experiencing
wildly different
equally valid
and
the complexity of simultaneous
experience is one access of choice
fortunately
this is something
that
technology gives us the tools
to deliver
so today we're going to drill down
on just
one example how many of you have heard
of audio description
okay
half a dozen that's
actually more than
i was expecting
so audio description is really just
translating relevant visual input into
auditory input
as an access technique this is primarily
used for
blind or low vision audiences
people who are primarily non-visual
so
real world example just something
simple to start us out with
woman in blue shirt
is
an example of alt text that was created
for this image
does woman in blue shirt tell you
anything useful
i had a discussion
to that effect
okay we get to pointing finger well
that's that's important but pointing
finger
smiling and pointing
okay we're getting somewhere now and
this is about the point where people
start arguing with me about alt text
character limits
which is true
and a problem
uh there are a variety of ways that you
can work around this
on the web of course by using aria roles
on social media by putting your
descriptions directly in captions or
comments
and there's a utility
to making things visible
if i were going to go for a full out
description here
i would
have to use a paragraph
to identify
everything that we can glean
visually from
this image
because
the color and styling of her hair tells
us something the fact that her jewelry
and her nail polish is matched to her
blouse
tells us something the quality
of her expression and the way that she's
holding her arms
a picture is worth a thousand words
right
you know here i got it down to 30 or so
let's take something a little more
complex
this is a rehearsal photo from a setup i
was testing a couple weeks ago
so
what would you choose to pull out here
as the important things what are the
bits that communicate
we can talk about what's going on
we can talk about the subject of the
photo
we can talk about
the context or the environment in this
case a rather messy theater
image description is complex
and subjective but fundamentally it's
about communication
that's pretty straightforward right
let's
go
if i can navigate the multiple screens
here
in unison they lean back in their
wheelchairs are carried into the air
they swing in long pendulous arcs
holding hands embracing then alice
hovers in front of laurel reaches back
to take laurel's hands and together they
swing they continue
this is one example of how audio
description is commonly done for video
and
this is
an excellent
interpretation uh one of the best
describers
that we can find and who i've worked
with extensively over the last few years
to create
uh specifically
equitable communicable content
but video description
of course
is even more complex
we have a range
of styles
you could say there are as many styles
of description as there are describers
it is a highly skilled
and technical form if you can imagine
sitting in front of
a play
a dance performance
and speaking
as rapidly as you can
to fit all of that in
to language
and
critically
i know this is weird but certain users
prefer different things
some people prefer a very objective
style
she raises her arm
pauses raises again
now lifts it overhead
she raises her arm like the ticking of a
clock
she raises her arm
as if thoughtfully brushing paint onto a
wall
these are all valid descriptions they
are all different styles they are all
communicative in different ways
so a couple years ago
we
were putting together the first kinetic
light performance
and we did what's called a work in
progress showing
that's where you invite people where
it's not finished
you know kind of like your alpha version
or
you know release day if you're a triple
a game company
so
we filled a theater with our
mentors
and our students
our friends some enemies
and put this out to about 200 people
in san francisco
and on the whole
it was
received incredibly
well
uh
you know for this the first time we
tried to do anything as artists of this
scale
there's just one problem
we'd hired
an excellent audio describer the best in
the bay for dance
and our blind friends came up to us
afterwards
and said
hey
we don't know what happened like people
were gasping
we could hear them
leaning forward in their seats
and there just wasn't anything that
exciting
in the audio description
not through any lack
of our describer
but
because no one person
can convey in narrow band speech
everything that's happening in
broadband
site
so we understood we have failed
after a long time
a lot of research
a lot of discussion
there were a handful of things we needed
to fix
first of course a rich and equitable
experience to sighted viewers
we needed to fix user agency
if you
are sighted and watching a dance you
might take in the whole stage you might
focus in on just
one dancer or one small section
you might close your eyes and listen to
the music
rather than
here's this
here's this option take it or leave it
um we needed to solve it being second
hand rather than first hand
equitable art is created by the artist
as a part of the creation
and when i say by the artists here
of course that might be a single person
is more likely a collective of
art
collaborators
no more made by one person
on the whole
then
any piece of software is created
by
one person
you know we have the same kinds of range
of collaborators and teams going on
and we had to solve for the communality
of the experience why do we go to
theaters
why do we go and why don't we
you know we've been getting along just
fine right watching movies in our living
room
you know maybe maybe you go out on the
street and if you've had bands set up in
your street and you watch them from the
porch so i go to a theater
because
most people
crave
having experiences
in community
so we can take from this that the
solution needs to be
aesthetically equitable
not equivalent but equitable
socially equitable
so not a segregated experience
but fully integrated in place and time
and delivery
and flexible as to the type
the medium
the complexity
the style
of the experience
so
i have
a little demo here but actually first
i'm going to ask you to imagine
this is a lovely big space imagine that
we have
speakers scattered through the space
maybe they're on the ceiling
maybe they're in mid-air
anywhere in the volume and let's make
this fun you can fly
so when you come into the space
you can make your way around the room
every speaker is playing a different
track
every track
is part of the same performance
so you can go cuddle up to one speaker
and listen from beginning to end
you can find a mix that pleases you
you can
wind your way
and keep moving
so that the experience is constantly
changing
as you listen to it
and it plays from beginning to the end
and then it's done
smush that up into a phone and that's
automates
what you're looking at here
is a little mocked up queuing interface
so remember that i talked briefly about
timing
for someone working in theater and
performance art timing
is absolutely everything
so the way that we solve this for stage
is
that this receives cues
from q lab
if you're not familiar that is simply
the most common piece of software used
to coordinate
all the technical components
of a performance
so in this case that means that there is
a live person
generally your stage manager that's kind
of the description of their job
who
calls
these events
they see something on stage
they trigger it someone pushes a button
on the computer that qlab is running on
and it sends a udp cue
of course the triggers can potentially
be anything
they can be uh based on
location
proximity
uh
some other device
that part is
you know not actually super important
and unfortunately
it does not seem
to want
to play just yet
which probably means we're having
difficulties
downloading it over the network
this is always the risk of live demos of
course
let's take one more try
all right we'll give that just a second
and if that doesn't work
i will bring up
some of the files
individually
so if you were looking into this over
headphones the sound is fully
spatialized
does that matter
well part of the trick here
is that
this application centers highly skilled
listeners
the way i knew i was on the right track
so this has
toured with the show these are examples
of real show tracks you see five here uh
there's nine running in the current
version that actually tours
uh but the very first show where
we ran this for a live audience i knew i
was on the right track when
a
fully sighted audience member who had
insisted
he wanted to try it
came up to me afterwards in meltdown
he was screaming and having a tantrum
um i looked at the logs later and he'd
made it
less than three minutes into the
performance
this is not designed
to center a sided user
this is designed to center
users whose primary mode of experience
is auditory so if you are trying to
watch and take in all of that
and trying to listen
even to only one track much less
multiple tracks
you're not going to be able to process
that
much like any of you who are teachers
probably have a fine grasp
that most people cannot
fully process
things that are written in things that
are heard at the same time that's why
you don't put wall of text on slides
right
so some of the examples of tracks here
uh there is
traditional description
up there in the right hand corner
there is
what we call ramp sounds
that were created by
miking the stage itself
as the performance happens so you get
the combined sounds of the stage and the
dancers bodies and that itself is
sub-spatialized
uh scene markers
uh simply kind of a play-by-play
of the
narrative play in poecy
soundscape
think radio lab
probably my favorite track personally
and character narrative down there in
the lower right corner is
essentially a radio play style
interpretation
so
let's see
if we go cowboy on this
and i think i've got just about 10
minutes left here so
if this doesn't work we will divert
to afterwards
i'll throw this over there i'm in the
developer sandbox running locally on my
machine now
so
take
a q there and
while we're here
let's go ahead and kill that
so the technical implementation is
almost absolutely simple frankly
in
essentially the alpha mode as a web app
this has been running on a dedicated
network
with a raspberry pi i've lived my life
in watery bingo far from slowly slowly
rolls her way back up to the top all
right nothing like a little reversal
of the plan
she sits up
takes hold of her i can have my cursor
back please and spins countered me
clockwise so now she's on her knees
facing left
and i was playing with a different
spatial model here
but
substantially that's partially up
online
so as we move forward
rolling and encouraging
here i'm just clicking edging closer to
it she rolls onto the surface nearly to
the top of the ramp
between crests
enter the trough
watery images are now gone and the
projection of a fetch guy steers from
the peak
as andromeda suddenly appears on the
back edge of the platform
it's message that i am remembering
onto the surface of the platform and
lies on her back so
i rise to a new surface
changing everything flexibly as we go
this allows audiences to choose one
track or many to choose their style to
choose if they want to listen to a mix
and to customize their experience
uh
and i would be remiss not to note that
all of this is with great thanks to
georgina cleage and josh mealy uh if
that last name sounds familiar
he's in the new batch of macarthur
fellows
for
work that
i have drawn heavily on
in order to create this
so designed to work with distracted
audiences
designed to work with terrible terrible
theater connections
and a wide variety of access needs or
desires
incredibly simple
as bulletproof and resilient as we could
make it
if you've ever tried to check your phone
in a theater
you have a good idea that the networks
are usually
kind of horrific
therefore also why we've been running a
dedicated network for it
in alpha
moving forward
this is an open source project
and we're building a substantial
coalition of support
the next stop is
of course taking it to a native mobile
version instead of a web app this is
necessary for a variety of reasons
including improved access to haptics
uh geolocation for geo-fencing
the ability to
auto play
yes
auto play because when you go in the
theater the performance
begins when it begins and you shouldn't
have to take an extra step
to initiate it
creator ui
which right now is
a
manual upload
as well as the
manual placement
of those spatialized tracks
i've actually been having a lot of fun
while this is in alpha taking the
listening data from
each performance and reshaping the
tracks based on that so basically
determining what people are listening to
and which combinations of things are
drawing high percentage values
and that separates out into roughly
three clusters of the nine tracks so
i've been using that to reshape
that
particular spatial set
but of course we need a
gooey version
of that
visual clone
our research
with deaf and hard of hearing artists
and audience members
suggests that there's a way in which we
can apply this
also to visual interpretation
so
just as it takes multiple kinds of
audible interpretation
a performance needs multiple kinds of
visual interpretation
venue ui
this should be plug and play for any
venue
to offer access consistently
for every show
because well by the way if you think
shows are accessible
i've got some bad news for you
performance enhancements down the road
uh
frankly it works surprisingly well right
now for something uh
that was created
out of need and dream and desire
so
thank you everybody
uh i think we've actually got maybe like
two minutes left for questions
two
absolutely
uh that is one of the reasons i
specifically mentioned
uh collaboration and the reality of
teams of collaborators
really creating any piece of art
there's a lot of ways you could approach
that
the one that i would probably use is to
bring in a collaborator
focused on that role
ideally
ideally that would be someone who has
access to all the other members of the
creative team
because okay you're describing the
actors you were describing the actors
bodies
they
ideally have a voice in that
you're describing the costumes you're
describing the lights and when you're
describing things there's a combination
of what are you seeing what are you
using your judgment to pick out that
that is communicating what is important
about that
and what was the artist's intent what is
the artist trying to communicate
uh
i find it helpful to work with a little
bit of both
so
you know obviously in some cases your
playwright
may be dead or may not be available
but you have your actors you have your
director you have your designers
uh
who can all become
part of this process
where
yeah it's not one person
um
nothing that makes it to stage
is ever just one creator
and um the art world has been a little
slow to
recognize that in a lot of ways you know
the director or the choreographer or
whatever is not
the sole artist
it's the
you know genius myth
in action on that side of things if you
will
so here's the thing about this system
most venues who provide audio
description by
large dedicated hardware systems
frequently operating via ir
or other line of sight methods they're
expensive they're clunky they're a pain
to install and they're a pain to use
and then to provide audio description
you have to bring in a live describer
we allow you to do the description from
anywhere
we're not taking away the job of
describer we're blowing it open
so
this uses the audience members own
personal hardware
when i talked about geofencing
you enter the theater
here's your show
so
for venues this is an incredibly
attractive proposition
for artists we're working with the
people who are excited
about the possibility of how
thinking in
these expanded ways
thinking about additional media
informs their work
if this is not for someone i'm not
interested in working with them
personally that's you know not any fun
and fortunately there are a lot of
people who are really excited about the
ways that this makes them better artists
and
i think that is our cue we are at time
thank you everybody for coming and
tweet me hit the slack channel uh or
grab me if you want to play with the
demo in more depth find the repo on
github
thank you all
[Applause]
[Music]
you